ira bomb on cds the vs reality of
intensive work we've managed to agree on
a general approach by member states on a
regulation on organic production and
labeling of organic products sadly
achievers product ahmardian trodden para
of David in our game at this regulation
is reduce obstacles to the development
of organic farming in the EU and to
assure conditions a fair competition for
all representatives of the sector with
you he outcome of today's discussions
about organics is certainly a very
reasonable approach notre who would
allow the council to engage very fully
with the report report air and the
shadow report a report of the european
parliament under mr. housing and i hope
that we will be able to get conclusions
in the european parliament now quickly
in no later than perhaps September in
order to allow trial acoustic to
commence and be completed before the end
of the year today's discussion in
Council they dealt mainly with the
fishing opportunities more and more we
are delivering on our commitment to
achieving maximum sustainability levels